one of the five of you guys is drunk
already we're gonna play a few games
you guys have to guess who it is just
keep your eyes peeled
to be anybody at the end i'll ask you
guys to
guess who you think is wrong twist we're
all drunk
[Music]
i
is that all the cards guys i can't get i
can't get more than one
that's an indication this isn't really
fair how are you still on the floor
because i hid like 40 under my skirt
one two three four twenty three
eight eleven five
nine who are the the fewest
[Music]
oh me all right
no i haven't played so long i've made a
mistake
it's only round one
oh this is like not good no i might
change my mind
[Music]
[Music]
you touched it you may have made a
massive mistake
[Applause]
have you played before
[Laughter]
she was overly confident
just touch the damn thing
don't get so aggressive i'm an
aggressive drunk
maybe we should have placed that before
the bed is dropped
uh yeah but like money's also better
money's greater oh the price is you win
a bottle of wine
oh wow all right
they're like the two drunk girls in the
bathroom that are hyping each other up
whoa she's not done
watch out she's a holder
[Music]
the movie is called eighth grade i don't
know about them i don't know
either three words
did you say three words
la la land
okay give me 20 minutes eight rounds
you know what you're drunk because you
haven't accused one person here being
drunk
because you know you're drunk that's
fair three words
first word hi
wave hello
classroom related
forgot how to do math do we have to do
like exactly twenty percent
oh god okay when you add the percent
to the total or what the percent is what
are you
um what is twenty percent oh my god
why are you doing the most commonly
very little time that's the tip
this is what i would do i think yours is
but we're close yeah oh we all got the
same reason
we have the same all you do is just take
ten percent and then
times it by two oh i didn't do that i
just did it the regular version i didn't
like
break it down i don't know what it is
who do you guys think maybe maybe it'd
be honestly
because that thing was hella long but
you've been looking drunk from the
beginning
you're very accusatory though so now oh
yeah
good lord okay well
can i start off with the fact that this
was used as a test
in uh japanese internment camps because
they knew that they would fail
she's drunk she's talking politics
[Music]
[Music]
h
[Music]
not drunk zyx
[Music]
put the sticker on the person that you
think is drunk
[Music]
badge of honor this is hard
can we smell them only because you
flipped them
should we just trade
i think that's a good guess you did act
the most drunk but i feel like that just
might be your personality could just be
a really fun person
yeah it's personality i might have to
change my
thing yeah like a personality wise like
i can't blame people
i'm so
[Music]
raise your hand if you're drunk
yes tell us a little bit about
what about myself i'm drunk
i drank zinfandel
this is zinfandel i'm hiding in a
meeting room
i was told to drink as much
as i can
[Music]
it was clear that you're drunk because
you tried so hard to pretend that you
weren't drunk
especially playing jenga you're like
trying to focus i think you had it when
you were like she's not accusing anyone
else
because everyone else is like drunk
drunk drunk i want to see what you're
like sober and see how they compare
just as fun
oh everybody wins a bottle
[Laughter]
where's my unfinished bottle though can
chess can i split that
you